bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau
7,8 le débat plus que quelques jours
avant les festivités du 14 juillet vous
serez sans doute nombreux à assister au
feu d'artifice ou balle de votre commune
sans oublier le défilé militaire sur les
champs elysées à la fois donc festive
mais aussi solennelle les cérémonies du
14 juillet célèbre plusieurs dates de
l'histoire mais que mettons à l'honneur
précisément la révolution française la
force militaire du pays où est
simplement un moment de joie et de fête
avec nous pour en parler ce soir
philippe korda vous êtes adjoint à la
culture de plaisir et frédéric lemoal
vous êtes professeur distance et
militaire de saint-cyr bonsoir messieurs
philippe korda qu'est-ce que vous
organisé cette année à plaisir et qu'est
ce que ça signifie pour vous votre
commune et ses habitants
écoutez chaque année bien sûr nous
célébrons le 14 juillet avec un feu
d'artifice un feu d'artifice dans le
parc du château de plaisir puisque on a
la chance d'avoir une esplanade de tout
à fait magnifique et je pense qu'on
évoquera tout à l'heure le fait que ces
feux d'artifice sont souvent tirés dans
des lieux magnifiques et pour une
première fois nous nous associons avec
nos voisins des clayes sous bois et en
mettant quelques moyens en commun pour
permettre un spectacle encore un petit
peu plus grandiose en tout cas toujours
aussi festif que diriez-vous que
signifie ce feu d'artifice
c'est un moment de convivialité
alors va écouter ses plusieurs choses à
la fois effectivement il ya ce côté
télévisuel on le voit de loin tout le
monde vient voir le feu d'artifice et on
peut le voir de loin
donc c'est effectivement avant tout un
spectacle mais c'est aussi un moment de
partage en famille
on voit bien que les parents viennent
avec leurs enfants les petits sur les
épaules
l'idée c'est de passer un moment festif
avec la côte et bien sûr le bal
populaire le fameux bal populaire où on
va danser pour ceux qui apprécient ce
genre de fait
voilà alors on voit que le 14 juillet
c'est plusieurs célébrations en même
temps 1 comparativement à d'autres jours
fériés ou c'est une date précise de
l'histoire
qu'est-ce qu'on célèbre on célèbre à la
fois la révolution française et puis
elles défilé militaire ou six on croit
souvent que l'on célèbre le 14 juillet
en réalité c'est pas tout à fait exact
ce qu'on commémore le 14 juillet c'est
la fête de la fédération c'est à dire le
14 juillet 17 ans 90
la première sert de commémoration du 14
juillet 1789 mais la fête de distin 90 à
un aspect plus unitaires plus convivial
puisque le 14 juillet 89 et quand même
anact quand même très très violent a
prise de la bastille qui avait entraîné
la mort de plusieurs personnes
alors que la fête de 1890 avait
rassemblé toute la nation
tous les différents mouvements partis
politiques de l'époque la monarchie
l'église et l'assemblée nationale et
dans les années 1880 la troisième
république a voulu faire du 14 juillet
une fête nationale républicaine est en
réalité nous commémorons celle de 1790
évidemment ça s'est perdu et tout le
monde croit que l'on fait celle du 14
juillet 1789 c'est cet esprit là ans
d'union cette fédération que l'on
célèbre même si on a un petit peu oublié
vous vous pensez
finalement ce que l'on célèbre
véritablement certainement oui puisque
c'est vraiment le côté festif qui
l'emportent avec ce feu d'artifice qui
paradoxalement date de la monarchie et
donc oui rappelons le a et voilà
les feux d'artifice royaux je crois que
le premier a été tirée au mariage de
louis xiii la place des vosges donc une
grande fête qui a duré beaucoup de
plusieurs jours d'ailleurs et qui a
ramené pas mal de monde et je crois que
le château de versailles enfin toutes
les fêtes fastueuses ont fait perdurer
cette tradition monarchique
mais c'est aussi un symbole de fête
comme vous l'avez rappelé qu'ils se
faire même en famille à la limite on
peut à la fin d'un mariage pour une fête
entre amis
maintenant les coûts sont la portée de
tout le monde et donc c'est un moment
festif partagé qu'il soit privé ou
effectivement pour ce fameux 14 juillet
et on n'oublie pas les valeurs de la
république c'est ce que vous me disiez
en prêt pendant l'émission
ça reste quand même
empreintes dans cette manifestation oui
on sent que les parents qui amènent les
enfants aux feux d'artifice cette
cérémonie le prennent sous l'angle
cérémonie également les valeurs de la
république liberté égalité fraternité
sont vraiment derrière on voit les
drapeaux français même s'il n'ya pas le
défilé militaire comme on peut la voir à
paris bien sûr on sent que ce sont les
valeurs de la république qui sont
l'occasion d'être un moment festif
alors justement avec le moelleux ce
défilé militaire ce qu'on ne sait pas
c'est qu'en réalité il a été fort la
tradition a démarré un siècle après la
révolution 1880 c'est ce que m'a
expliqué les premiers l'aspect militaire
il apparaît dès la révolution française
à l'époque du directoire puisque la
révolution elles célèbrent l'armé qui
est l'armé de la nation qui est
représentative de la nation puisque on a
une armée à l'époque de conscription
donc c'est le pop qui qui combat donc
c'est ce peuple en armes qui est
célébrée et puis a effectivement la
troisième république va reprendre cet
aspect de deux défilés militaires
puisqu'il s'agit de glorifier l'armée
après la défaite de 1870 contre la
prusse et il y a dans les années 1880
avant la sphère dreyfus une vraie
ferveur pour plus populaires pardon en
faveur des des soldats bien qu'après il
ya un antimilitarisme qui apparaissent
dans les rangs du parti socialiste dans
les mouvements syndicaux qui va poursui
qui va se poursuivre pendant toute
l'histoire la dernière vraiment pulsions
antimilitariste en france et les années
60-70 ça s'atténue aujourd'hui mais
enfin il y a quand même eu cet
attachement à l'armée parce qu'en france
tout est lié c'est l'armée du peuple et
la nation se confond avec la république
depuis la révolution française donc et
tout ça en fait que nous célébrons le 14
juillet et c'est une spécificité
française c'est à dire qu' une telle
démonstration de force militaire
n'existe pas vraiment ailleurs ou dans
quelques poches sans doute dans quelques
pays mais c'est quand même assez assez
rare c'est une vraie spécificité
française aura bien sûr à paris
centralisée
oblige pas toujours évidemment aux
champs elysées le défilé a énormément
varier dans paris avant 1914 ça se passe
dans l'hippodrome de longchamp ce qu'on
appelle la fameuse revue de longchamp
qui était très très populaire et puis ça
le défilé a commencé à se mettre en
place sur les champs-elysées à la
première guerre mondiale
c'est devenu une tradition d'ailleurs si
ton cette date de 1919 c'est le grand
défilé de 1919 le grand défilé de la
victoire
toute l'armée toutes les armées alliées
ont défilé avec l'armée française pour
commémorer évidemment on est le 14
juillet 1919 commémorer la
la victoire bon c'est toujours plus ou
moins rester dans le quartier champs
elysées concorde invalides ça a bougé
l'internât fois que ça bouge et voilà il
ya un symbole très fort au centre de
paris
la dernière fois que le défilé à bouger
c'est à l'époque de valéry giscard
d'estaing en 1974 valéry giscard
d'estaing voulait va modifier beaucoup
de traditions et le défilé en 74 par
exemple a eu lieu dans les quartiers
populaires de paris autour de la place
de la bastille ce n'est pas en soi un
idiot et puis finalement bourre après le
septennat de valéry giscard d'estaing
ses revenus aux champs-elysées ça n'a
plus bougé depuis fini car là est ce que
vous sentez chez les jeunes un
attachement à ces célébrations
oui c'est vraiment inter-générationnelle
ya ce côté spectaculaire je crois qui
prime le feu d'artifice est toujours
mise en scène avec bien sûr son et
lumière donc on a aussi de la musique
populaire qui soutient je dirais le feu
d'artifice les moyens techniques une
mise en oeuvre maintenant son
fantastique puisque on peut avoir des
effets de lumière avec les lasers on
peut avoir bien sûr des synchronisation
parfaite grâce à l'informatique
donc on sent que l'accompagnement
vraiment scénographique la mise en scène
grandiose devant un bel espace culturel
fait partie de toutes les générations
imaginez ne pas avoir de feux d'artifice
ou de célébrations une année c'est
impensable
oui alors vous avez raison c'est
vraiment impensable surtout que c'est un
spectacle aussi qui se veut gratuit
parce qu'il n'y a pas de sens de
d'offrir un feu d'artifice autrement que
gratuit puisque on célèbre la nation
alors effectivement avec nos voisins des
clayes-sous-bois on a essayé de
neutraliser un petit peu nos efforts et
on a la chance donc un plaisir d'avoir
l'esplanade
la plus propice je dirais à ce
rassemblement parce que on attend quand
même plusieurs milliers de personnes et
du coup même si les clayes-sous-bois ne
souhaitait peut-être pas le faire
exactement cette année elle ne pouvait
pas ne pas le faire avec lui vous
parliez donc de du rôle pardon de ses
défilés militaires aujourd'hui à quoi
sert ces démonstrations de force donc on
a plus de guerre en europe du moins
donc c'est de la diplomatie pas
seulement il ya un aspect ya l'aspect
diplomatique dont je veux dire un mot en
effet mais il ya aussi l'aspect
militaire la france est un des rares
pays aujourd'hui en europe avec le
royaume uni qui veut conserver un outil
militaire qui se sert de son outil
militaire à des fins diplomatique pour
défendre les intérêts de la france à
l'étranger
je vais bien sûr allusion aux opérations
extérieures menées par l'armée française
en grande partie en afrique ne faut pas
oublier aujourd'hui que l'armée elle est
impliquée sur le territoire du fait des
attaques terroristes
donc il ya une véritable volonté de
démonstration de force alors bien sûr
guillemets pacifique puisque non plus
nos voisins depuis depuis longtemps mais
enfin il ya quand même cet aspect
militaire et puis il ya aussi a bien sûr
un aspect politique effectivement
diplomatique que l'on voit dans les
invitations qu'ils sont qui sont lancés
la dernière en date c'est l'invitation
fait par le président macron de recevoir
le président
trump donc il y a un aspect diplomatique
lorsque nous voulons honorer un allié
nous invitons le chef d'état où le chef
de gouvernement et un contingent des
soldats de ce pays défilent aux côtés de
l'armée française
on peut aussi ça est arrivé en 2008
invité plusieurs chefs d'état avec les
cas nous sommes en négociation c'est ce
qu'avait fait le président sarkozy
lorsqu'il négocie à l'union pour la
méditerranée où on avait reçu
pratiquement tous les chefs d'état
autour de la méditerranée y compris
bachar el-assad à l'époque mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ça ne se reproduira pas
en effet philippe korda est ce qu on
peut imaginer
peut-être pas plaisir mais en tout cas à
l'échelle d'un département
un autre défilé militaire je crois que
ça se fait dans d'autres communes dans
d'autres villes c'est pas seulement à
paris l'ensemble honnêtement pour
l'instant je n'en ai pas entendu parler
mais pourquoi pas il est clair que comme
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le moal
valoriser notre armée valoriser nos
soldats qui savent nous défendre en
particulier dans cette période un petit
peu tendus avec la menace terroriste est
quelque chose de très important et on
doit on se doit effectivement de les
honorer
dès que possible allez deux petits mots
de conclusion chacun on arrive à la fin
de cette émision c'était mission pardon
monsieur le moal qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez peut-être une évolution de ce
défilé militaire est ce que vous avez
envie d'une innovation n'ont pas de nom
pas très favorable aux innovations
je trouve que c'est très bien ce défilé
militaire puisque ça rend aussi
charnelle attachement à la à la nation
et je crois que l'on a on a vraiment
besoin parce qu'il faut toujours dans un
pays trouver quelque chose qui unit la
population est bien l'armé peut-être ce
point ce point d'union parce qu'il faut
pas oublier non plus que c'est un
ascenseur social selon remarquable
encore de nos jours
de votre côté je ne peux pas ne pas
évoquer malheureusement l'attentât de
nice l'année dernière au 14 juillet qui
nous a émus au niveau de la nation
entière et qui bien sûr sera sans doute
un petit peu quand même dans l'esprit
des gens au moment de cette fête
mais bien sûr je ne peux que souhaiter
que l'on perdure cette tradition pendant
de longues années et que la république
puisque oms a montré ses valeurs à
l'ensemble de la population
et justement dispositif de sécurité de
votre côté
bien oui effectivement le dispositif de
sécurité est tout à fait adapté et il a
été bien sûr renforcé double avantage
aussi de s'associer avec notre ville
voisine pour avoir les moyens à la
hauteur de ce que l'on pourrait
éventuellement redouté en tout cas nous
sommes sereins nous avons préparé tout
ce qu'il faut venez nombreux le feu sera
magnifique
très bien merci à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à cette émission
c'était la dernière émission de la
saison bel été sur tv 78 au revoir
[Musique]